just healed my hand with an added Papa
don't get sauce all right y'all I'm
gonna make arepas con queso from Encanto
corn flour I used about two cups I just
got this from the international market
add some warm water and salt and then
just mix it with your hands I also added
some butter and once it looked like this
I added in the cheese knead until smooth
and then let it rest for 15 minutes now
I'm rolling it in my hands and forming
it into this like Patty shape then I add
the cheese into the middle I folded up
the corners and then rolled it until it
was smooth and then flattened it out and
it became this little cheese filled
Patty then I fried them on medium to low
heat for about five minutes on each side
and they were nice and golden and that's
about it I hope I made these correctly
they were very cheesy and delicious yeah
yeah